free to one action je m'appelle sonia
mladenov a et je suis la responsable de
la programmation ses productions
spectrum chez production spectrum on
accueille les jeunes autistes puis on
offre de la formation des outils de
création médiatique
nous avons six programmes différentes et
à chaque programme vise le développement
des compétences techniques mais aussi
des compétences sociales et aussi la
confiance en soi
[Musique]
les deux fondateurs de production
spectrum étaient des éducateurs
spécialisés et ils ont noté qu'il ya
vraiment une affinité entre l'autisme et
les médias certaines de leurs élèves
avaient des compétences très forte
technique avec le désir d'exprimer leurs
sentiments et des idées à partir de la
création
près l'âge de 21 ans pour ce jour là il
a très peu d'opportunités pour
développer à leur copain taxe
professionnelle ou d'avoir un emploi
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que il est
une perception dont la société qui est
les autistes peuvent travailler des
tâches répétitifs ou routinière on
essaie vraiment de ramener cette
conversation vers la créativité
les participants sont divers vous pouvez
trouver des gens qui composent la
musique des jeunes animateurs
d'animation 2d au 3d des monteurs ou
a développé son propre show de cuisine
twitpic
c'était un rêve sont choquantes 80
épisodes tout notre chaîne youtube de
l'est
ils tombent chaque semaine avec une
équipe de participants d'ici c'est très
important parce qu'il peut sentir que
leur travail est plus qu ils peuvent
être fiers de ce qu'ils ont montré
[Musique]
spectron production existe depuis huit
ans il a plusieurs cas où une personne
qui a été ici qui a été formé ici peut
aller à l'université après ça pouvoir
avoir un diplôme
notre bus de élargir notre partenariat
avec des employeurs externe
il est à plus de 150 personnes qui
passent par spectron parent et des
personnes autistes sont aussi des
employés ici on peut vraiment voir
comment
aide aux jeunes autistes de trouver leur
parcours dans la vie de trouver ce
qu'ils veulent faire vraiment
[Musique]